This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is brought to you by the folks of Conahoe Creek Outfitters.
They know camping and they know scouts. They are scouts
And they know how to get you great gear and great prices for all your camping adventures.
So go visit them at conahoecreakcom, at conohocreakcom.
And now to your Scoutmaster.
We should go back and look at what the real official list of duties is for a Scoutmaster,
And this is actually hidden in the committee materials.
They don't put that in the Scoutmaster handbook
Because I don't think anybody would ever do the job.
It's like you know who's going to volunteer to jump in the volcano,
But the crops will be great,
But you're going to not be coming back.
Yeah, we'll be the same afterwards,
As people could tell who listened to us.
Hey, some of us jump into the volcano and some of us get thrown in.
Oh well, this is podcast number 160..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag this week
And here we have a message from John Mitchell, who is the committee chair of troop one in Orange County Council.
He said: I love the article you referenced over on Bob White's Blather about helicopter scouters.
I even put it in our weekly parents newsletter.
I observed some helicopter scouters this weekend and I thought I'd share.
There was another large troop camping next to us and they had an awful lot of parents with them.
Their camp kitchen was in close proximity to us and I watched them over the weekend.
I never saw a single scout enter the kitchen to light a stove or heat some water or clean a dish.
The parents and the Scoutmaster did everything.
Our boys kind of hunkered down over their backpack stoves and heated cup of noodles or toasted, a pop tart.
It's the same everywhere, isn't it?
That's the same menu: cup of noodles and pop tarts.
I'm sure our Scouts would have loved to have been all fat and happy while we did all the work,
but instead they took care of their own needs a hundred percent.
Near the end of the weekend our Scoutmaster and I struck up a conversation with a couple of the other troops leaders.
We told them how we did a lot of backpacking.
Their leaders said that they had a hard time getting their boys interested in that type of activity
and they really did wish that they could do more.
As I thought about it later, I was struck by the fact that their boys aren't interested in that type of activity
because it'd be so different for them.
They would have to carry their own gear and feed and take care of themselves.
I was actually not surprised about their Scouts attitude.
That sort of independence is a culture that needs to be deliberately woven into the personality of the truth.
Lord Baden Powell was right when he said
when you want a thing done, don't do it yourself is a good motto for Scoutmasters.
Thanks, Clark, for the website and the podcast and everything you do for Scouting.
You're a great resource.
Well, thank you, John.
Thanks for the kind words and the story.
I think you know we've all encountered that type of thing before
and it's interesting to see the contrast between the way troops are run.
And I think you know boys get a lot out of Scouting no matter how the troop is run.
They can get more when you run it the way the program goes.
but it's always interesting to see those contrasts.
Larry Green was in touch and Larry Green is in North Myrtle Beach, South Carolina, with troop 888.
And he said: I love what you say about pioneering legend John Thurman.
My mentor, the late Adolf Peschke, also extolled the virtues of the Japanese Mark II square lashing.
Hey, if you haven't been to the blog in a while. go take a look at the Japanese Mark II square lashing.
I mean, you know it's a pretty great lashing
And if you're a not geek like me, you know it's something that you got to know.
Larry Green- and no relation there, strangely enough- has a blog at scoutpioneeringatscrrcom-
Scoutpioneeringatscrrcom,
And you need to get over and take a look at his great pioneering resource.
And thanks, Larry. Thanks for being in touch.
Dave is in Santa Rosa, California, with troop 55 and pack 134..
He said this: I'm an Eagle Scout that wears many scouting hats, including district chair, camp director, assistant scout master, cub master and assistant, then leader.
I only discovered your podcast about a month ago and have listened my way through the archive up to number 140..
I find that I'm able to apply so much of what I learned by listening to your podcast. to each of the varied positions.
I noticed how the changes you made to the site. it's a much cleaner look and I like it. Keep up the good work.
Well, thanks, Dave. Thanks for being in touch and thanks for the kind words.
Scoutmastercgcom went through a redesign. Go over, check it out, Tell me what you think.
There's more to come and you know I'll be tweaking it and working on it probably forever, but it's in one iteration now that I'm pretty happy with.
And thanks again, Dave. Chris Beaver wrote in to say I can hardly believe it's been close to a year and a half since I was chosen to be the scout master of my troop here in Madison, Wisconsin.
The biggest reward has been working with a few particular boys who don't really have a father figure at home.
It's been interesting to see them mature in just a short span of time.
In fact, one of those boys was elected to senior patrol leader.
We have four new scouts who just crossed over from Weevilos and they're an absolute joy to have at meetings.
They're so enthusiastic. it's a nice change from the older kind of jaded boys who've been with the troop for several years.
Even though I was a teenager, I still have a lot to learn about working with those guys, as do we all. Chris,
The next stage of my wood batch ticket is to carry it out in an open house for our troop next month.
I'm hoping we get to spread the word to the community about what our troop does and perhaps at the same time recruit some new scouts.
Well, keep carrying on. I always enjoy the posts and the podcasts.
Thanks so much, Chris, and thanks for being in touch. Now let's listen to this.
What's time again to talk to our friends at ConahoeCreekcom. How are you doing, Bill?
Doing great, Clark.
That's Bill Fleming on the phone with me there. We've been talking about the knife sale at ConahoeCreekcom.
Every day this month there's a new knife on sale. It will be featured at 10% off and then it will be on sale for the remainder of the month.
Plus, you can add a special coupon code just for listeners to scoutmastercgcom.
CG113 is the coupon code That gives you an additional 5% off for 15% off on some really great knives.
The one I'm looking at right now, Bill, is from Victorinox. I think everybody knows Victorinox,
but tell us a little bit about that brand.
Well, that is the Swiss Army brand and that ought to ring a bell with everyone.
This particular knife that you're talking about is the Huntsman, and they have a Boy Scout model.
It has a variety of tools that come in such a nice little package.
This one is the one that I carry. You know, one of my favorite features on this is that saw.
That saw will cut things that you would not think you would be able to cut with a knife saw like that.
It's unbelievable what those little saws will do and they never seem to get dull.
No, mine's been around for years and still works great.
This one has the saw of the scissors, wire stripper, the small and large blades, the can opener, a hook.
It's got the tweezers, It's got the toothpick.
It's kind of the full boat on a Swiss Army knife, without getting too ridiculous.
This one's got the red handles. It has the Boy Scout emblem.
You've got another one on there called the Boy Scout Climber II and it's got yellow handles.
You know what I would do with this? If your scout has lost more than one knife, this is the one to have,
because he's going to have a hard time misplacing this one.
Yeah, those bright yellow handles stand out. so if you drop the knife, it's easy to find
and certainly has all the tools that you need as well.
The deal on these is that for the month of February at ConahoeCreekcom
there'll be a new knife that will go on sale every day.
It will be reduced by 10%
Once it goes on sale. it'll stay on sale all the way through the month of February
and you can use your coupon code for listeners to the Scout Master Podcast CG113,
and that gets you an extra 5%.
So you'll get 15% off on any knife. that's part of the sale this month at ConahoeCreekcom.
Thanks Bill,
Thank you Clark, and we'll see you at the creek.
Here's a reminder that the next Scout Circle- you can find out all about it at scoutsercleorg-
is going to be Sunday, March 10th, from 9 to 10 pm Eastern Standard Time.
Our guest will be long-serving troop committee chair Frank Maynard,
who's blogs at Bob White Blather.
He'll be there to talk to us about troop committee issues.
So that is something that you'll definitely want to tune in to see.
Once again, scoutsercleorg.
That'll be Sunday, March 10th, between 9 and 10 pm Eastern Standard Time.
In this podcast we have our February Scout Master Panel discussion.
So, without further ado, let's get started, shall we?
It's time for another Scout Master Panel discussion.
Well, it's time for another Scout Master Panel discussion,
and joining us are the usual suspects.
Larry Geiger is down in Vera, Florida.
How are you doing, Larry
Hey Clark? Good.
And Tom Gillard is in Tolahoma, Tennessee.
Hey, Tom
Hey Clark, How are you?
And Walter Underwood is out there in Palo Alto, California.
Good evening, Walter
Howdy.
We have snow on the mountains and it's pleasant here in the valley.
You need that snow.
Yeah,
Larry, how much snow down there.
It was 27 this past weekend.
So our guys- seven guys- are going to get Polar Bear Awards.
Our definition is below 32..
Until a snow camping trip- recent snow camping trip-
the coldest night I ever spent camping was actually my Weeblows night
with Troop 26 in Baton Rouge, and it got down to 18 degrees.
We've been out on a winter campery trip
and it was down to minus five.
I got it beat
Minus 10..
Ah,
That is cold.
I've only been down to zero, but that was cold enough.
You've got to be ready for those.
So Larry's definition of Polar Bear is 32..
Yeah,
It's 32 outside my window right now.
I'd get a Polar Bear patch every time I walked outside the past
week or two-
Me too,
I know.
So you got to sleep in it, Clark.
Oh well, I keep the window open.
32 is where it's, just getting comfortable for my sleep,
Right.
Yeah,
We're going to answer a couple of email questions tonight,
And the first one is from a parent whose son has just been
elected to be a patrol leader, and this is what he had
to say: fellas,
My son has started attending patrol leader councils
and I've been trying to educate myself on the patrol
method since I noticed that the patrol leader council
meetings were pretty poorly attended.
The true path is about 46 boys.
Whenever one becomes first class, he becomes eligible to
run for senior patrol leader.
If he's elected senior patrol leader, he's moved to our
senior patrol, consisting of five older boys.
All the boys in our senior patrol have positions of
leadership that they maintain across elections, including
the assistant senior patrol leader.
Now, after reading your articles, I asked our
scout master about this and told him that this did
not seem to be the right arrangement.
He answered that that's how everybody does it and
that these boys need these positions for rank
advancement and if they didn't have these
positions they would quit.
And his question is: is this really common?
Well, the first thing: I mean it stands out
If every six months he's got a new senior patrol
leader and he's got 46 scouts and there's only
five older guys, I'm still curious.
Anyway, the numbers don't sound right to me.
The second thing is that clearly he's running
things. he's just assigning them positions and
then the positions of leadership that they
maintain across elections. elections don't
have anything to do with leadership positions.
they're appointed.
So every time a new SPL comes in he's
appointing the same guys to the same position.
Whose idea was that?
I mean, that's not the boys' idea, because
that's not how they would do it.
We had some disagreement back and forth about
senior patrol and whether the SPL
and SPL is in a patrol, and I finally
actually found in the senior patrol
leader's handbook, which again is a
wonderful book, that the SPL and the
SPL are not in a patrol.
Everybody else is in a patrol.
But once you're not an ASPL or not an SPL,
then hey, you're in a patrol.
Yeah
Well, the way I've done that in the past
is that the senior patrol leader is not
really in a patrol, though he eats with a
patrol, but the ASPL is the patrol
leader. he's the ASPL but he's also the
patrol leader for the guys that are
officers in the troop and that's
usually a kind of a senior patrol
thing.
Senior patrol leader: he may be directing
what's going on, but the fallback
position is he's going to eat with his
old patrol, the patrol that he came out
of most of the time,
Because, like you said, in theory there's
only two or three scouts that are in
the senior patrol, so that doesn't
really make a good number.
So they just fall back to doing
whatever. you know pretty much whoever
they want to eat with. usually it's their
old patrol.
When I had 80 scouts and we were
camping 50 to 60 every month, I had
a full patrol. I had three or four or
five instructors, quartermaster scribe,
one or two other chaplains, aid,
So those guys were all in a patrol
and they were eight, nine, ten guys
out of 55. They weren't the senior
patrol. we didn't call it that. they were
a patrol and usually they're the guys
that wanted to hang out together. anyway,
Most of them were 14 and above and the
other patrols were younger and we let
the guys form their own patrols with
whoever they wanted to. As I've said in
the past one year, they were the ten
patrol and their flag was a stick with
a number 10 can upside down stapled to
it. They never would tell me if it was
the 10 T-E-N or the T-I-N, The 10..
So was it a number 10 patrol or a T-I-N?
10 can't? patrol Works both ways. We ain't
telling you, Mr Geiger, Works both ways.
If we look at the book- either the
Scoutmasters Handbook or the Senior
Patrol Leaders Handbook- everybody in
the troop is in patrols. They elect a
patrol leader for each patrol. everybody
in the troop elects a senior patrol
leader. The senior patrol leader appoints
the other officers that he needs to get
the job done. That may be an assistant
senior patrol leader if it's merited,
A quartermaster, a scribe, a librarian,
a historian, whatever. And the practice
of putting all of those officers into one
patrol is not what you would call
strictly wrong, and some people do that
and they get along just fine. and Larry
described the situation where that works.
Reserving leadership positions for older
boys- that's another part of this question-
is if reserving the leadership positions
only for those older boys, because if
they didn't have them they wouldn't be
able to advance or they might quit- I
just don't see that as being cricket.
Yeah, I totally agree that anybody
that's first class is eligible to be
to be one of those positions, and the
SPL should take that into account.
Nobody has a permanent position.
The first class requirement is not a
BSA requirement. That can be one that
the troop adopts, but any boy of any
rank can actually have any one of those positions.
Yes, that's true, but usually the
scouts that are asking for positions
are the ones that have acquired first
class, unless you just have a bunch of
guys below first class. They're the
ones Usually you're working on Star
Life. you want a position? you go tell
the SPL: I want to be scribe or
something, and it's kind of usually
in a troop that's fairly large and has
a bunch of guys. usually a tenor foot
scout's not asking to be ASPL usually,
but there's nothing wrong with that.
A second class scout can be scribe
or whatever. You could have somebody
joined when they're 13 and they're
coming up through the ranks and they're
plenty. they're the best person for that job.
I've had that Right. and then the
younger scouts can be some of these
positions within the patrol so they can
start getting experience. for when they
do turn first class and actually need
to step out to the troop side of things,
Yeah, usually they're quarter master,
assistant, patrol leader or patrol leader
in the patrol. That's where you
commonly find like a second class scout
might be a patrol leader or system
patroller. I think a lot of you know.
as we can see, there's a lot of variation
in this whole senior patrol and whatever
There's. you know there's plenty
of ways to do it and I don't think it's
a huge deal. but there should not be
some permanent leadership group.
There's a lot of things that indicate
that maybe the scout master is running
the troop a little bit more than he ought to be
If the patrol leaders council meetings
aren't being, if they're poorly
attended. boys don't normally want
to spend a whole lot of time doing
something that they don't either
like or that actually produces
no results. I've seen this pretty
often: the idea of kind of preserving
those leadership positions for, you know,
a specific group of older guys. I think
a lot of times adults don't think
that boys can make these decisions
and that if they were to allow them to
do so, the things would start to fall
apart. But I know that within our
experience we're pretty sure that
that's not true. And another thing
you emphasize, Clark, is that
advancement doesn't drive the program.
The program drives advance. You know,
we're not here to advance, We're here
to do the program and advancement
really flows from doing that. And
so you do the program and if they
get positions and they advance,
then that's part of their doing the
program as it should be done.
We tend to turn those things on their
head and we think that we need to
adjust things so that advancement
happens, rather than just doing
scouting and letting advancement
happen that way.
Well, it's a cart before the horse
thing, right? It's definitely
a method towards
character, citizenship and fitness.
So here you are. You've gotten
involved with the troop and you've
come up against something that
like this situation where
you find that you know it's not
really in line with what
your understanding of the program is.
You study it a little bit and
you find that, wow, I think we're
kind of out of whack here
and that the troop has gotten
off course. How do we
get it back on course?
If I'm the parent of a scout
or an assistant scout master
and I see that there
are problems like this,
what actions do I
take to help the troop get
back on course?
I guess it just depends on the
intimacy of the person.
How unchanging
is he going to be?
This is a nice place if you've
got a good commissioner
to come in and say: you guys
have a great troop. Here's some
things about the scouted
program we can clean up.
He comes in as
somebody that knows about
scouting but is not in the
middle of any politics, hopefully.
Would anybody recommend that
it's a good idea just to come in
with a complete challenge and say:
I think you're wrong and you need
to change this.
If the scout master is wrong,
if he's not doing youth protection,
if he's not too deep leadership,
if he's not, whatever. yet
that's when you bring down the hammer.
In this case, he's got 46 boys,
he's got a PLC.
that's a little out of whack.
The question is is how far
a field is he?
In a case like this, some subtlety
is called for.
We would all agree, I think, that if it was
an issue of youth protection
or somehow there were other
actions that were impinging on the
safety of the scouts,
Or he redefined first class rank
or whatever,
That would be something that you would
challenge,
Blighten problems.
I don't think any of us would
recommend that. it would
be a good idea to show up
and tell the scout master what he's
doing wrong.
I'd come in and say: here's
another right way to do it.
Whether it's wrong or not
doesn't matter if you get it
changed. Adjustments, improvements.
I talk to the boys.
I wouldn't go around the scout master
necessarily, but once we're
talking about it I would say:
here's how the troops do it. Here's what it says
in the book. What do you think?
Let's say that you're in that situation.
You've suggested some ideas
in the way that Walter says it.
You keep getting pushed back
and you don't get a response.
Where do you go and what do you do?
at that point? There may not be a lot
you can do. You may have to just move
to another troop, And that's a perfectly
legitimate thing to do. Yes,
My advice to people usually
if they have a very sharp disagreement
with the way things are happening, is
not to try by might or
mean, you know, change things around
to a way they want to see it,
even if that is more consistent
with the program as they read it,
But to find somebody who gets
the way that they want to see it and go
and be part of that troop and also,
maybe other stuff is working
well in the troop, You know. so,
yes, this seems a little off course,
but do the
kind of go across the eight methods,
see what's going on. If there's kind of
it's kind of weak across the board,
Well
then there's a lot of stuff. The other email I receive
that I thought would be
interesting to talk about was this one:
Our scout master of over 12 years
has recently announced he plans to
retire from the troop. He's leaving
a great legacy behind with a large
and healthy troop and we have several
great current active of all
adults that I hope will step up and
provide some choices
for our new scout master.
Do you know any good resources
or do you have any ideas
about the scout master selection
process for an existing troop?
Larry, you've been through that process
several times. Yeah well,
it's basically up
up to the head of the institution and
the chartered organization rep
to choose a scout master. They're in charge
of leadership. It should be
done in conjunction with the committee chairman.
The best thing
is to see who's interested
and the committee chair
and the COR sit down and talk to
them and see if
they can figure out a way to get
a good guy. But you know, I've
always communicated with my committee
chairman and my COR and I've usually
had a pretty good one.
When I'm coming and going.
you guys are in charge.
this is your thing, not
my thing. There
is a thing in scouting about.
you can't go till you pick your successor.
I really think
that the guy leaving
should just go.
The existing people and
the leadership should then
take up their responsibility and
decide.
I've felt that way too,
not that I'm getting ready to go yet,
but if the when the
day comes that I do,
don't pick, don't get
into it, Don't pick your successor.
that, like you said, that's the
charter rep guy.
That's their thing.
We've been pretty lucky. One of
the things that we do is just people are
in it for about three years or so.
You know we don't have somebody stick around for a long
time. Often the
scout master is going on to be
an ASM, working
with the venture patrol and high-adventure
stuff, because that's a nice progress,
along with their son.
What I'm hearing is
is that if you have a scout
master, especially someone who's served- this
particular one served for about 12
years or over 12
years. the email says he's
getting ready to retire. There are
some possible candidates and
the people who should be making that
decision
are the troop committee chairman
and the chartered organization
representative- They're the ones who
are charged with
that responsibility-
And the head of the institution. if that
person is actively
involved, I would say, because
somebody's been doing it for quite a
while, we should go back and look at
what the real official
list of duties is for a scout master,
And this is actually hidden
in the
troop committee materials.
Don't put that in the scout master
handbook because I don't think anybody
would ever do the job.
It's
like you know
who's going to volunteer to jump in the
volcano.
The crops will be great,
But you're going to not
be coming back. unfortunately,
It won't be the same afterwards
as
people could tell who listened to us.
But
take a look at what.
which ones of the things on that list
make sense for
the people you have And you maybe
shuffle on stuff around. Maybe this guy's been doing
stuff and it's kind of settled into the scout master job,
But really
that should be an outings
chair or should be somebody else.
Yes,
Take a look at
re-juggling things a little bit.
You're right,
Because when we first
got started-
and it was me and my wife and maybe
one other person
and we had the kids and we had
a couple of adults,
but we didn't have a full committee
and yeah, I was doing some extra stuff.
but boy, it felt good when we
had somebody and
said, oh, you can do
money. Well, how about
being the treasurer
And start handing this stuff
off to people and
never touch it again?
is what you try for?
We don't have a treasurer
right now. Well, I'm not going to do it. I'm sorry,
but I don't want the money.
So I think
that's good advice
from the both of you- that
when you have somebody
in that position who's been serving a long time,
you might want to
reset some
expectations.
A scout master that's been around for
10 or more years is going to have
their way of doing things
and while that might work,
while they are there,
they could leave a pretty big hole behind.
It'll be an old shoe
for somebody who walks into the job.
Yeah,
That shoe is not going to fit
Head down to Tom McCann and get a new pair.
Yep,
Thank you, Somebody got
Tom McCann. I figured it was a shoe store,
but I don't know what it is.
Yeah,
We had one of those down on government.
Even Tom is not Okay.
So with both of these questions, I think what
we've discovered is the importance
of the different roles that are involved
with having a troop.
while whoever is
the chartered organization representative
may not be called on on a weekly basis
or a monthly basis,
they have a very important role
in what the troop does
and defining what that's going to be
and in selecting leaders,
as does the committee,
and again, this isn't something that
they're doing
on a weekly or a monthly basis,
so it may take
a little catching up and a little bit of
training, familiarizing
yourself with the different
resources,
and I'll make sure to link to the ones
that we've mentioned here
in the post that contains this podcast.
Well, it's exactly
the same as with the boys.
if you run
the troop meetings, if you take over,
then
eventually they're just going to get bored
and wander off. but the same thing is true
of the adults.
If you give them a position
and then they never do anything,
if they're ready to go,
but somebody else is always
just running around behind them,
even something
like COR that doesn't
isn't as active. if they are
engaged and they
actually have the responsibility
to work with the committee chair to make that decision,
even though it's not
every month,
they're going to actually
be more involved in their position
if they're actually being responsible
for something. It works
the same
with the committee as it does
with the scouts.
It's just the shared responsibility
of running this whole
thing that we've got going,
the scouting program.
That was my thought too,
that the other aspect of this
is that it's a team. You've got
ASM, Scout Master Committee.
you've got a bunch of people- parents,
people
pick people for their strengths
and put together a group
that can do the job
because it's fun doing stuff you're good at.
so make sure that you've got at least come kind of
match with what you like
to do and are good at and the job
Absolutely.
I tell everybody-
and I've said this before-
but me, and when I'm Scout, Master,
me and the committee chair do everything,
we do everything in the troop.
we want to help, we want you to help
where you want to help
and if we've got everything covered except treasure,
one of us will be the treasure.
but we're not going to tell you
not to be the advancement
person because we need a chairman.
if that's what you want to do, do that
and everything will go much better.
if you're doing that,
even if we're doing treasure,
then if we try to make you do something that you don't want to do,
is after about a year, year and a half,
you just got people all around you
and over all kind of stuff.
I've gone from committees of three
or four to 15
in a room every month,
15 to 18,
and everybody's got something they're doing.
however big it gets,
all the jobs get smaller.
Hard to say it better than that.
Well, thanks once again,
fellas for joining us.
Larry, keep warm down there.
you know 32, man,
that's got to be brutal.
thanks, Larry.
goodnight Clark.
Tom, thanks very much for joining us again.
it's been a pleasure. Clark
and Walter, keep that
snow coming down out there, would you-
you bet the sun is set on the snow-covered mountains here-
and stay out of the volcano.
yeah
well, thanks again
for listening,
and here's how you can keep in touch.
read the scoutmaster blog
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
while you're there, you can
listen
and listen
and listen.
well, thanks again for listening,
and here's how you can keep in touch.
read the scoutmaster blog
at ScoutmasterCGcom
while you're there. you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email.
you can also subscribe to the scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes and, when you do,
feel free to leave a comment or review
or a rating,
you can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
get details about how to do that
at Stitchercom.
you can experience the wonders of ScoutmasterCGcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets:
ScoutmasterBlog on Facebook,
ScoutmasterCG on Twitter,
and we do have the exclusive
ScoutmasterCG circle
for those of you who are on
Google Plus,
remember, you can always email me
and the email address is Clark
C-L-A-R-K-E.
at ScoutmasterCGcom,
the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed,
sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
until next time
you.